[Music]
I'll be a very early birthday present
for Bruno Mars if he wins one or all of
his six Grammy nominations Sunday night
got a pretty good chance there anything
yes and for Bruno while it takes a
village Cameron Mathison back in Los
Angeles and the Absolut Limon green room
with the man behind some of Bruno's big
hits thanks guys and just like the mix
for the perfect cocktail you got to have
the mix just right to have that perfect
Grammy performance and I'm sitting here
with the guy who knows a thing or two
about that good to see you again good
did you want to open this weekend Philip
Lawrence of course Bruno Mars co-writer
and producing partner he's the guy
driving while Bruno rides shotgun in
24-karat magic I'm a dangerous man with
some money in my pocket uh he's right
behind him in uptown funk and he
co-wrote Leo's latest hit finesse
he's also got four Grammy nominations of
his own and this year on Sunday he'll be
right there on stage with so if you had
to break it down uh-huh they're like
three key ingredients for the perfect
Grammy performance what do you need to
make sure that you have if I had to make
this thing we kind of had a segue to
church right there if I had to break
this thing Wow
it's most important to start with the
vision so we leave that up to Bruno and
then you have to have rehearsal what are
you looking at we're looking at usual 10
to 12 hour days this song in particular
you know where we're doing something
fresh I don't want to give it away okay
but it's gonna be a lot of fun key
ingredient number three a little bit the
moves oh you gotta have the move the
guys have been working on those moves
for about a month now Philip tried to
teach me the signature and groove yeah I
don't think I'll be joining their world
tour anytime soon but before he heads
back out with the band the dad of five
will be hitting the Grammys sting
congratulations on the four Grammy
nominations in fact let's have a little
toast right here this is an absolute lie
about me that's for you thank you
absolutely live vodka Rita it's a
signature Grammy week cocktail cheers to
you two
[Music]
you